الطريق الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب نحو البيت الابيض بالطبع هي محفوفه
بالمخاطر لكن ما يساعد المهمه هو المواجهه
امام صديق الامس رود ديسانتس فحاكم ولايه
فلوريدا الجمهوري سيكون منافسا على بطاقه
الترشح عن الحزب الجمهوري للانتخابات
عشرين اربعه وعشرين العديد من المصادر
اشارت الى ان ديسان السي يعلن ترشحه رسميا
للانتخابات الرئاسه الاسبوع المقبل وهذا
الترشح من شانه ان يثير حفيظه ترند في ظل
شعبيه ديسانتوس المتزايده وقدرته على جمع
اموال ضخمه لدعم حملته الانتخابيه
المنافسه طبعا ستكون مشاهدينا ستكون على
اشدها بين الرجلين في ظل العلاقه القويه
التي كانت تربطهما قبل ان تنقلب الى عداوه
ترامب لم يتاخر في توجيه سهام الانتقاد
للسانتوس خصوصا مع التزامه الترشح بشكل
رسمي واستغل ترامب هزيمه الجمهوريين في
مدينه جاكسون فيل بولايه فلوريدا لمهاجمه
ديسانتوس وتحميله مسؤوليه تراجع هيمنه
جمهورينا على الولايه وكتبت رام في منشور
على منصته داتروس سوشل ان سحر ديسانتوس قد
ذهب مضيفا ان خساره مرشحه كانت خساره
صادمه في جاكسون
ولكن رغم صعود اسهم ديسانتوس في الحزب
الجمهوري بعد فوزه بولايه جديده على راس
فلوريدا نهايه السنه الماضيه غير ان شعبيه
الرجل قد تكون تراجعت نسبيا في الفتره
الاخيره وهو ما اشار اليه استطلاع للراء
الحديث كشف ان واحدا 61% من الاخبين
المحتمدين للحزب الجمهوري سيدعمون ترامب
في انتخابات 20 24 مقابل 18
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات